luego de haber rebasado en días
recientes el millón de contagios de kobe
19 e incluso antes de haber alcanzado
este jueves la cifra de los 100.000
muertos por coronavirus los estados que
están en color rojo del semáforo
epidemiológico y los que han retrocedido
a naranja han reforzado las medidas
preventivas para evitar repuntes por
ejemplo los congresos estatales de
chihuahua sonora nuevo león jalisco
guanajuato y zacatecas han establecido
el uso obligatorio de cubrebocas en vía
pública y de no acatarse esta
disposición se contemplan sanciones
económicas o incluso cárcel las horas de
arresto varía en cada entidad los
estados en color rojo son chihuahua y
durango sin embargo en la capital del
país no se ven las hospitalizaciones e
incluso van al alza es por ello que se
ha determinado aplicar los fines de
semana la ley seca es decir prohibir la
venta de bebidas alcohólicas para
desincentivar las fiestas y reuniones
privadas pues se ha detectado que son
focos de contagios en la mayoría de los
estados en naranja y rojo
se han restringido los horarios de venta
y de servicio de establecimientos
comerciales considerados esenciales y
también de los no esenciales el país
tiene la esperanza puesta en la vacuna
pues forma parte de mecanismos como el
kóvacs o tiene acuerdos para tener
acceso garantizado al fármaco de
laboratorios como pzifer astrazéneca
modernas o cancino